last week we did a story about the
clearly bogus donald trump medical
letter talking about how he had done
astonishingly well on every test that
was done back in december we did a
detailed report on it the story did well
we estimate a total viewership of about
350,000 views across all platforms for
that story a ton of emails came in about
it and all of a sudden corporate media
is getting interested in the story louis
i turn on CNN last night and there's a
panel discussion on Don lemons show
about the the trustworthiness of Donald
Trump's medical letter looking at
reporting of it today countless websites
talking about it and now that I've had a
little more time to look into this
medical letter about how fantastic and
tremendous Donald Trump's medical state
is and how he's winning again and again
with his with his status of health it's
even sketchier than we reported last
week so let me get you up to speed let's
first put up the original letter and
I'll just quickly remind you of all the
issues for it number one the letter
starts with a typo to whom my concern
which is just weird for such such a
short letter the letter has a nonworking
web address where when you go to that
website there's just no website there
for the doctor who supposedly did this
examination the doctor number one
included an email address which is weird
because you don't want to get emails
about something like a letter like this
because HIPAA laws would prevent you
from saying anything more but it's also
weird that the email address listed is a
personal gmail address
imagine a you know hi I'm the CEO of
Ford Motor Company I'd like to do
business with you please email me at
mark field Oh two three six at
hotmail.com no it doesn't make any sense
so come on and then in addition to that
Lennox Hill Hospital has a division of
Gastroenterology but for some reason the
signature of the trumps letter refers to
the gastroenterology section which dr.
Harold Bornstein is not even a part of
at Lenox Hill Hospital and lastly the
entire language of the letter where
tests are described as only
positive when in medical language
positive means that test has confirmed a
diagnosis or condition and of course
lastly referring to Trump is potentially
the healthiest president ever when there
is no way that Herald Bornstein MD
examined all other presidents and would
have any way of comparing Trump's health
to those other presidents so every news
site has basically been pointing out how
ridiculous this entire stink thing is
those were the problems we already
reported to you last week we now have
even more insanity to report to you a
number of sites have gone back to look
at Donald Trump's social media posts
when this letter came out you might
remember I told you last week that Jacob
Bornstein had actually been deceased for
years at the time of the publication of
this letter and the letter was signed by
at least in this version Herald
Bornstein it turns out that Donald Trump
posted to both Facebook and Twitter that
this was a letter signing off on his
tremendously positive health and results
signed by Jacob Bornstein a doctor who
had been dead for years at the time this
was released now these posts have been
deleted from the internet but thanks to
something called print screen' there are
still records of these and here's the
the Facebook post that Donald Trump put
out back in December saying I am proud
to share this report written by the
highly respected doctor jacob Bornstein
of Lennox Hill Hospital stating that I
am in excellent health unfortunately dr.
Jacob Bornstein had been dead for years
at the time that Donald Trump published
Facebook the assertion that this dead
doctor Lewis had signed off on how great
Trump's health is this is completely
bogus and we actually need to see
Trump's medical records all the debunked
conspiracies about Hillary Clinton's
health we have no idea what Trump's
medical records actually say and we have
no idea what Trump's tax returns
actually say we have nothing about
Donald Trump that letter at
this point can we say it is absolutely
bogus and fake I'm comfortable saying
that yes and I'm far more interested
though in the tax returns than I am to
Donald Trump's medical records I I agree
because I don't have any conspiracy
theories about Donald Trump's health but
if he has to fake a letter it's odd
yeah why do you have to fake the letter
doesn't really make any sense so yeah
this story completely blowing up we need
to demand not only the tax returns but
because Trump himself has put out what
seems to be a clearly fraudulent letter
we also need to figure out what the hell
is going on as Donald Trump would say
with that medical and health situation